Adam rip on is in the house spilling the
tea on Harry Styles plus I'm taking you
guys inside Lords stadium tour and of
course it is new music Friday happy
Friday everybody so surprised if you
watch yesterday's live show then you
know that Olympic medalist Adam rip ha
was here I know I'm sorry I didn't warn
you but I wanted to make sure he would
actually make it and boy did he show up
now we've covered a lot of ground with
Adam mimosas will do that to you but you
know we just had to ask him about his
number one celeb crush Harry Styles
Harry caused quite a stir this week
after he performed an unreleased song
called medicine at a tour stop in Paris
so here's the deal
the lyrics had fans questioning whether
Harry was coming out as bisexual the
lyrics in question the boys and the
girls are here I mess around with him
and I'm okay with it
fans were quick to call it a nu by
anthem and as you can imagine that got
the attention of Adam rip on he tweeted
and just like that my skin is clear my
vision is corrected and I'm suddenly
bisexual well here's what the Olympian
really thought Harry was trying to say I
think that he's been such like an ally
of like the LGBTQ community and pretty
much like unabashedly himself and his
like career and you know he's like a
young kid who's like our age were young
and we're hip and um you know I think
he's just sort of like on a journey and
he doesn't really care and I hope that
like young kids can like look to that
and they can really you know go on a
journey of like self-discovery and learn
who they are and I think he's sending a
really positive message and then when I
saw that I dropped my phone I threw it
and I said where the hell is he mm-hmm
well I do recall Adam telling Ellen
he might have moved on from Harry to
Shawn Mendes but you did have a chance
meeting at the Vanity Fair Oscar party
so let's settle it then Adam who do you
prefer shag marry kill you ready yeah
Shawn Mendes Harry Styles Nick Jonas
why oh my god cuz that's not right it's
brunch we're having fun there's mimosas
I want to know shag marry kill alright
and Shawn Mendes Harry Styles are you
gonna answer it - or is this okay I will
answer if you answer okay
Mary oh my god this is like so hard I
didn't know I was gonna answer this
either so now I'm like freaking out okay
no okay okay can i I think I know Mary
Shawn Mendes shag Harry Styles kill Nick
Jonas that's not okay since you answered
I'm gonna go Nick deserves more than
that and better than that does which is
why I'm gonna shag him I'm gonna share
Jonas I'm gonna marry oh I don't want
the one Directioners to come at me but I
think I'm gonna marry Shawn Mendes and
kill Harry Styles ah I'm sorry we just
lived two different lives I just can't
see ya alive and dad I do not come for
me Directioners it was hard to choose
how do you choose no I'm really asking
shag marry or kill Shawn Mendes Harry
Styles Nick Jonas take it to the
comments if your turn to answer and I
cannot wait to see your choices right in
the meantime head over to ET online.com
slash daily danny for more gems from
Adam there were plenty including whether
he'll be joining Dancing with the Stars
and speaking of dancing actually Lorde
brought the dance party to the Staples
Center in LA Wednesday night for her
melodrama world tour
I was there and it was so much freaking
fun I thought you guys should know that
if she's hitting your city run don't
walk and then when you get there dance
your face off in fact be prepared
because she'll demand it the concert was
jam-packed with all her hits like at one
point I checked to see if she would
breathe it and no one was more excited
to be playing to a nearly sold-out
stadium than lured the girl hit the
stage and rocked three different costume
changes include
this sheer floral trenchcoat with
matching pants this black maxi skirt and
long-sleeve top and finally this pink
ruffled number looking like a genie in a
bottle while there were no signs of her
pal Taylor Swift in the crowd her
collaborator and one-time rumored love
Jack Antonoff was there and she gave him
a special shout out during the show
affectionately calling him Jackie you
know Lord also subtly addressed the me
to movement after singing yellow flicker
beat saying she's loved performing that
song this year because it's about bad
men getting their comeuppance and you
better preach Lord anyway I just had a
gush about her because the show was so
epic so thank you for letting me and if
you don't get to go see her and a city
near you
then head over to my Instagram I put a
Instagram story highlight for you of her
concert alright before we go and enjoy
our weekend let me hit you with our new
music Friday pics starting with Charlie
puth who dropped this amazing collab
with Kalani called done for me
[Music]
[Music]
and you know I like to throw in a couple
jammers for you guys like inhale by DJ
Duke Dumont featuring FME sir
[Music]
don't need a guilty
[Music]
you look like a Friday nights house I
wanna take you to Yo no one takes me to
an imaginary island like Duke de ma
okay and bring in the sexy this week is
kygo who teamed up with Miguel for their
track remind me to forget
[Music]
alright there you guys have it your new
music Friday picks go and enjoy your
weekend we'll be back on Monday with
another daily Dani so make sure you guys
are subscribed to our channel and I'll
see you then I love that song
[Music]